this is a obviously the first nato
summit of the
new u.s president joe biden a chance to
reconfirm the importance of the
transatlantic alliance which i know
the president believes very strongly but
also a chance for us to come together as
as nato 30 nations protecting a billion
people it's not just about
protecting territory it's about
protecting our way of life so we'll be
having some
discussions about uh all the
issues that we face around us the
the threats that we face we'll be
discussing
afghanistan we're looking at ukraine uh
and also the waves we want to modernize
nato supporting
secretary general jens stoltenberg's
excellent uh
2030 uh project and
it's very much in tune with what the uk
government is doing with our
integrated reviews so nato has to to
modernize nato is modernizing nato is
investing ever more in
in cyber and so is the uk government
don't forget
we are now we're still the second
biggest uh
military contributor to nato but we've
just done a
big big step up another 24 billion
pounds
uh 2.3 percent of our gdp uh going on
defense
and that's because we see the vital
importance of
uh security making sure that we're all
looking after each other as we
as we build back better from the
pandemic you've got to be safe
for your prosperity so that's that's
what we're going to be working on today
thank you very much sir do you share
president biden's
opinion that china is a threat that nato
has not taken seriously enough until now
i think that china is as i've said many
times a gigantic
fact in our lives and a new strategic
consideration
for for nato which after all has spent
so much of its time in the last
72 years thinking about uh the
uh the soviet union then of course the
the former soviet union
the the various security threats uh
posed from
from that area but i think
when it comes to china you've got a i
don't think anybody
around the table today wants to descend
into a new
cold war with china i don't think that's
where people are but i think people see
they say they see challenges they see
things that we have to manage together
but they also see
opportunities and i think that what we
need to do is is do it together it's a
very very successful
alliance as i never tire of telling you
it's the most successful
military alliance in uh in history it's
done very
good job of protecting the people of
this continent and it's going to
continue to do so
cold war russia are you going back to
this um
i'm always hopeful that things will
improve with
uh with russia but the we've never
i'm i'm afraid that so far it's been
pretty disappointing from the uk
uh point of view and i know that when
uh and i when i saw president uh putin
i made that very clear i said look you
know uh we're ready to
uh to do things differently we're ready
to uh
to to try to have closer relations but
you've got to change the way you
behave and you remember what happened at
salisbury where
uh innocent members of the public
uh faced the poisoning from novichok
where one a woman tragically lost her
life
uh and that's no way to behave nato
allies stood by
by britain denner i know that uh
president biden
will be taking some pretty tough
messages to
president putin in the course of the
next few days